[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships I'm your host Jade warshaw
I am joined by one of my favorite
co-host Rachel Cruz bestselling author
host of The Rachel Cruz show and we are
joined together
join forces to answer answer your
questions about life money relationships
the holiday season whatever is sticking
in your crawl we are going to help it
come out of your crawl as we take your
calls give us a call the number Isle
8825 5225 and we'll chop it up with you
let's go straight to the phone lines
we've got LJ from Tulsa Oklahoma what's
going on
LJ uh yes uh thanks for taking my call
no problem how can we help um I'm trying
kind of new to all this I just recently
heard about y'all because some friends
are talking about a concept of debt
snowball versus a debt
Avalanche and it got me curious so I
started looking and researching up and
found the baby steps and I got some
savings but so I'm trying to pay off
thatt so I'm looking all the places to
get my like Hands-On money you know to
help pay debt off yeah and I have a 401k
that they call the target date 401K from
a previous job
um is there any downsides or is that a
good place to look at getting money to
help pay off debt since I'm currently in
a four or 457 at my new job yeah I mean
I love the fact that you're looking for
ways to pay off your debt and I love
that you feel that it's urgent for you
to quickly get your debt paid off but I
would not pull from retirement Savings
of any kind in order to do that and you
know the fact that you once had a 401k
and now you have a 457 that's not really
a license to do that because it's still
retirement money and so there's still
penalties and fees if you were to dip
into that money um not to mention that's
not truly the solution right we don't
want you robbing from Peter to PayPal
and so I think the solution for you is
probably going to be finding that money
either by picking up extra work or
cutting back areas in your budget LJ
you're your 401k that was with your
previous job is it still there have you
rolled it over into a traditional IR
uh it's still with the company that I
left it with okay so I would recommend
actually taking that out and just
rolling it over to a traditional IRA one
of our smart Vestor Pros in your area
can help you do that um but yeah we
don't I wouldn't leave my 401K with a
job that I'm not at currently so rolling
that over just to Ira is is one move you
could do it won't help with the debt
payoff but it will help with your
investing uh overall picture
MH okay so not to put it with the new
457 government program that I have no I
would keep it separate in just a
traditional IRA yeah so that you're not
paying taxes and then uh how much debt
do you have
LJ uh about 33,000 okay and how much do
you make a year count my mortgage um me
and the wife combined make about 90 okay
that's great look you can be out of this
debt in a year I mean if you were if you
guys decided hey we're going to live on
60,000 you're out in 12 months and
that's not That's not including extra
side hustles which you could easily
decide to pick
up right so what do you think about
that that actually sounds really good I
it'd be awesome to get out of all this
debt do does it seem possible like when
I said that did you go oh yeah we can do
that or was that like H you're right
Jade what did you
think well I I it it sounds great um I
just thought it would take more like two
or three years no I the good news is you
can do this really quickly I mean just
looking at the numbers and like I said
you guys cutting down your lifestyle
which is going to take you guys getting
on a budget which are you already on a
budget uh a loose one a loose one what
are you using is it what are you using
currently uh we just run our numbers to
a you know like sell spreadsheets yeah
well I want to get you guys hooked up
with every dollar because it is the best
budgeting app that is out there and
it'll help you get a really really clear
picture on what your numbers are every
single month and it'll help you set
those goals you can really get in there
and see like to the date when you're
going to be done paying off your debt
and you get to adjust that money and
adjust those payments in order to get it
done either faster or push it down a
little bit so that's our gift to you
today look I'm really proud of you
that's a really really great call thank
you so much for the call LJ look you can
do it and I think a lot of people Rachel
do think that oh I can get out of debt
but it's going to take me all these
years in the future yeah but then when
they really start crunching the numbers
they're like hey I can do this even
faster than I what I once thought I
could exactly
all right let's go to Kevin he's in
Houston Texas what's going on Kevin
let's make it a quick one hey how you
doing doing good how are you finally
talk to you guys you
too so I I'll make it short and simple
um I just paid off like $10,000 in
credit card Deb I'm on baby step number
two good for you so my next uh loan to
attack is my truck loan okay and it's my
only thing I have left but it's a high
one it's
around $83,000 left
whoa it used to be 94 it used to be
94,000 but now it's at 83 because I make
extra payments what kind of truck is
this this is a souped up Ford F250
Lariat is it for
work purposes uh no it's just pure
luxury I'm one of those that just has
the truck for luxury I don't pull
nothing how much do you make a year
Kevin um I make about 14,000 a month
okay yeah g like sometimes it could be
10 12 14 dep how much I want to work I'm
selling
it yeah I'm selling it I would Kevin
$83,000 in a truck that's that has debt
that's going down in value that you're
paying interest
on wow yeah it it took me like a while
to get it because it was like I had to
pre-order I believe it I'm sure you did
yeah I bet and uh so I do want to add it
to the to the dead snowball but I just
I'm trying to figure out how to go about
it if I should just pay more every month
or just save up one giant and just pay
no no you want to be paying on it yes as
as you get extra cash flow you're
throwing it at the truck but we would I
mean I would run the numbers Kevin I
would Kelly Blue Book it run a scenario
look on craigslist look at you know
local dealerships for other trucks and
just for a for a second just think oh my
gosh because how much is your payment
it's about 1,700 a month oh Lord sell it
Kevin Kevin Kevin run the numbers okay
go to ramsy solutions.com and pull up
our investment calculator if you
invested
$1,700 a month if you invested that
Kevin do you know how much money you
would have I wish I had my computer on I
would do it right now my go I'm a
skeleton I'm dead I am just wow and do
you have other debt besides this or is
this going to be
it this is it this is really my only
payment I have a month it's because all
all my other expenses are paid for so
wow Rachel you keep the conversation
going I'll do the investment calcul you
got to go we got like we got 30 seconds
okay I would I mean Kevin I I'm not
going to sit here and like convince you
you're you're a grown man you can do
what you want but but our biggest goal
is that we want your money working for
you not against you there is so much of
your income and hard you you make
incredible money I mean 150 to 160 a
year that actually be Building Wealth
for your family you could actually be
changing your legacy and building your
wealth with this versus sending it to uh
where Ford Motor Company or wherever it
is going right so so there's there's
power and letting your money work for
you versus it working for a car
dealership and that's what you're doing
right now with this truck wow if you it
if you did 1,700 a month two
$2,225 after 25 years 25 years you could
have $2 million this is the ramsy
[Music]
show well you've all played the
telephone game the first person Whispers
a message to the second person who
Whispers it to the third and so on
around the table until the original
message has completely changed multiply
that confusion by a 100 if you run a
business with different software Ware
systems that don't talk to each other
that's why there's netw Suite by Oracle
in the early days of Ramsey we were
using different systems for all of our
business units we needed one single
source for accurate data net Suite was
the software we use to optimize and take
us to the next level netsuite gave us
the visibility into all of our numbers
so that we could communicate across
departments and plan ahead better and as
we grew it scaled with us
net week worked for ramsy and it will
make a difference for your business too
join the more than 34,000 customers who
trust netsuite to help make them smarter
and make better decisions and level up
their operations to learn more get a
free product tour at netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
you're listening to the ramsy show I'm
Jade warshaw joined by Rachel Cruz give
us a call the number is 8825 5225 we'd
be happy to hear from you we'll go
straight to the phone lines where we've
got Caleb in North Carol in what's going
on
Caleb um hi so my question is so I work
with my dad after I'm done with school
like two or three times a week uhuh and
I make like $80 a week and I want to
know what I can do with my money right
now to set up myself for my future my
goodness Caleb how old are
you I'm 12 wow that's so impressive what
kind of work do you do with your
dad we go go to people's houses and fix
like washers dishwashers
refrigerators and like microwaves and
stuff like that wow Caleb let me tell
you not just the money you earn is
helpful but knowing how to do all of
that later in life in about 10 years I
know right people will be very thankful
to be your friends because you not not a
lot of people know how to fix all that
stuff Caleb so I love that you're even
learning that that trade now that's
amazing amazing
well uh I would I would love to hear
what would say about this cuz we both
have kids Caleb so we think about this a
lot for our kids but the fact that
you're earning money like this I think
is fantastic so I think the first
conversation I would have looking to the
Future the next the big purchase you'll
probably have in your future is a car
when you turn 16 so I would ask your
parents what their plan is for that if
they have um if they were thinking about
you know if they would have the money
that they were going to plan on maybe
buying you a used car car or if they
were going to expect you to maybe pay
for that or maybe they would match what
you save but I would I would probably
have a conversation first and foremost
about a car which seems kind of far away
I know you're 12 and 16 seems far but
there's really um besid just buying some
things that you may just want for fun uh
I think working towards a big purchase
is a really great goal at your age I'd
agree with that yeah I I use every
dollar and I have my um finan plan for
um December 80% of my stuff into um 80%
of my money into savings and then 10%
into ties and 10% into fun money wow
good for you Caleb so what do you spend
money on right now as a 12-year-old what
are things that are fun for you to spend
money
on well to be honest I I like I like
going I like I spend it on video games
to be honest yeah hey that's great
that's great that's great good for you
Caleb wow very impressive and your
parents look when you get off the phone
give your parents a big hug because they
have really taught you well and for
those listening he is doing right like
you do three things with money you can
give it save it or spend it so he's
decided to save 80% which is a lot
that's a lot great that's that's great
and then you're giving 10% and spending
10% and in your case yeah I think
spinning on video games sounds wonderful
I don't have anything to add to this
Caleb I just want to say thank you for
your call you're doing such a good job
come over to my house and fix the
dishwasher you know what I'm saying or
be a co-host here and help some people
out cuz you're doing real good for 12
years old wow I know that's right shout
out to the parents I know well done so
great thanks for calling Caleb thank you
so much oh my goodness let's go to
Lauren in Dallas Texas what's going on
in your world
Lauren hi so my mother-in-law lives with
us um she's going to be moving out in
June when our lease is up um our rent
is400 and she pays 800 of that so I'm
getting a raise in January which will
increase our income about 550 a month um
my question is since we're kind of
paycheck to pay check right now um
should we use the rise to save for a
security deposit and moving expenses and
move somewhere Le less expensive in June
or should we use the um the raise to pay
off debt until the lease is up and then
stay in our current home come June H the
leas is up in June um how much you guys
make a
month um currently about 106 um with my
raise will be up to about 115 but a
year yes okay okay and what do you take
home each month like what do you see
when you take home your check each
month um
about 55 55 okay good um how much debt
do you guys
have the why of it um with cars credit
cards u medical debt student loans um
all that were at about a 100 okay
thousand okay 100,000 and you said it's
cars medical debt credit cards just kind
of
normal yeah well with your current
income yeah $2,400 a month for rent I
mean that's that's pumping up to close
to half your your income so uh I yeah
that this is too of an expensive place
Lauren that where you guys currently are
um so if your lease is up in June I mean
you probably can't I don't know if you
can break the lease or what if you can
move out sooner but um I would work
towards looking for a new place in June
uh especially since your mother-in-law
is not going to be living with you guys
um yep find the the cheapest place that
you can can and then um from there start
working the debt snowball but between
now and then I would I would I would
start the debt snowball though Lauren I
would I would find that what is your
smallest
debt out of everything you listed
probably a credit card okay which is how
much how much do you on that uh 2,000
okay so yeah I would make it a goal you
know to start chipping that away and and
um working extra and I guess is the 115
a year include you and you and your
husband's income
yes okay so yeah I I mean you have a
yeah I mean you're you're making good
money but you also have a good amount of
debt 100 100K so I'm going to say that
there's probably going to be a season of
side hustles and earning some extra
income do you guys have
kids yeah we have three okay wow okay um
so yeah so that's always a tricky thing
to navigate and Jade I know you and Sam
did that with kids too and so like it
just that adds a dynamic that's very
real yeah um um that makes it difficult
but I think for you guys to be as
focused as possible and map this out but
I I sadly Lauren I don't I I can't in
good faith tell you to stay where you
are when half of your income's going to
be going into this rent because it's
just it's you guys will not be able to
get traction of paying off this debt no
definitely not I look I agree
wholeheartedly um have you priced out
some cheaper apartments in your
area yeah we're current we have two dogs
also so we're in a house right now so I
feel like we need to stay in a house
just because they're a family of five
with two dogs and it's a little chaotic
in an apartment I can imagine so um
we're kind of on the outskirts of Dallas
where it's cheaper but I'm not sure kind
of what we what we can find that's going
to fit us um that's going to be cheaper
yeah you got to find you're definitely
going to need to find something
otherwise I mean it goes one or two ways
you either see your income going up
substantially like 25% more to where
this knocks down to where it's supposed
to be
or you find an apartment or a home to
rent that's 25% less yeah and Lauren and
remember this is just for this is
temporary which I I I know it's like it
sounds it sounds it's easy on our side
of the desk to be like go find another
place to move and you're thinking of all
the logistics anding your family like I
know it's a lot I know yeah I mean it's
it is it's a lot so there's either going
to have to be what Jade said substantial
income raises that you guys are just
working extra but I don't want you to do
that to have to float a necessary
payment like rent right like if you're
doing that to pay off debt that's a
seasonal thing but I don't want your
lifestyle currently where you guys you
you just can't afford where you live and
so I think that there is going to have
to be some really hard conversations and
and it's kind of one of those things
Lauren you know choosing your hard and
we talk about this a lot like where you
are now currently with money is hard
right you're feeling the stress you're
feeling like oh my gosh we have so much
debt I I'm I don't like this like that's
hard it's also hard to move and to
downsize and to make some tough
decisions with schools and the logistics
of your family that's not fun that's
hard but at least at the end of that
hard there's a level of peace that comes
because you can actually breathe and get
some control where this hard that you're
in if you just stay where you are
literally physically in that house but
also where you are financially it's
going to continue to have this hard and
I would choose the latter the ladder
hard I would too because like you said
that intensity that you put in that's
not supposed to be your the your life is
lived like you'll just everything you do
is like I'm just working to live you
know I'm just working to do this house
payment and then you're going to hate
your house because oh it's taking you
away from your kids stff yeah it does
it's a burden not a blessing that we
talk about a lot on this show that's
right this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$55,000 seller guarantee gives your
offer the best chance of being accepted
the home buyer Edge from Churchill gives
you an advantage over those other guys
go to Churchill mortgage.com today to
learn
[Music]
more
what's going on friends you're listening
to the Ramsay show I am your host this
hour Jade warshaw joined along with
bestselling author
and author of the new book I'm glad for
what I have yes yes love it right Rachel
Cruz is sitting next to me today and
we're taking your calls about your life
and your money so give us a call the
number is
5225 and I have to tell you guys um it's
always an exciting day when someone pops
into the office and is like Jade have
you seen this lady
video on Tik Tok and I'm always like no
I haven't because I don't hang out on
Tik Tok but I'm always very entertained
on what they bring and so today there
was a video that came across Rachel and
I was like this is crazy you haven't
seen it yet no I not but I thought it
would be cool and James was like hey we
need to watch this and we need to see
you guys' reaction to it so go ahead and
give it a
whirl I feel like my husband and I are
doing everything
right we both have good jobs I'm a nurse
I'm a registered nurse I work full-time
he works full-time we just got paid this
past Friday right we paid the
mortgage bought some groceries put some
gas in the car and guys it is
Tuesday and we have like $200 or
$300 to last us until next Friday like
we don't live in a big house we we live
in little ranch it's 1100 square ft
three bedrooms one bath us and our two
kids I'm so stressed out this isn't how
it's supposed to
be you growing up we were told go to
college get a degree work to support
your
family here we are did that now
what now
what wow oh man listen
you should know that we did edit it down
that that video quite a bit because it
was pretty long okay and she's emotional
the entire time and she also does
mention Rachel that she works full-time
as a registered nurse her husband works
full-time as well and does side work
okay I have two kids is what she says
and she says in the video that we just
got paid on Friday mhm paid the mortgage
yeah just mortgage gas and groceries and
now to only have $2 to $300 that's like
the yeah
that's crazy look I have my take on and
you tell me yours whoa okay um my
kneejerk
is I feel like we get callers like this
a lot I do I mean I feel like the state
of money is not always pretty and it's
and it's really stressful MH and even
when you do you know we even talk to
people on baby STS four through six and
they're like oh my gosh it still kind of
feels tight because like we're having
the fun kids you know and all of that is
is is real but they're not at a breaking
point at which she is at so my natural
reaction is how much is the mortgage
yeah how much are you guys making a
month what other debt so you just got
paid yes and you only have three two so
that means the if they only really if
they really only did groceries gas and
mortgage that means yes there's a ratio
that could be off somewhere yes and and
if you only have $200 to $300 left in
your account that means the other
paycheck you got $15 days ago is gone
too what is that going to are there
other payments you know what I mean like
as it starts to decrease that much well
let's look at this in a real way okay so
let's say she got paid on the 30th which
is like the first for most people okay
and if they paid their whole mortgage
that's most people's biggest bill so if
that's gone and then if they spent half
their grocery money half their gas money
then I'm like okay the next check is if
they've got two kids we don't know how
old they are let's say they're in
daycare age maybe the next biggest chunk
goes to daycare then the other half goes
to gas other half goes to groceries my
question still is if you can only pay
three things then there's something
ratio there's a ratio that's off yes
like we say 25% for housing mhm but also
I would want to know where where where
else is that right so like where did the
15th paycheck from the month before yes
where is that allo yes is there payments
two car payments sitting in the driveway
you know what I mean like I want to know
so many other things I mean she she says
quote we did every we've done everything
right which I feel because that is that
is a sentiment what she said is you're
told go to college in fact when I went
to school you know which was 15 years
ago there was no even talk
of of hey let's look at Price Texs it
was really go where you can get in you
go and you'll get a great job working 40
hours a week everything's going to be
fine right and she says I don't know if
it was in this video cuz I've seen both
versions did did she say that she's
going to school fulltime too no she's
going to okay so that wasn't in the clip
guys she's going to school full-time as
well which is a big expense so here's my
take here's this is just me she says
okay I'm working full-time going to
school full-time papa is working
full-time he's got a second job plus two
kids forget finances I'm just crying
every day anyway because that's just a
lot like let's be honest that's just a
lot in life overwhelmed the number of
hours in a day so part of me also feels
like
there could be a piece of this that's
like if she's going to school full
stress is somewhere else too yeah I'm
like it stress will make everything seem
worse right and when you feel stretched
on your time it makes everything harder
like those $300 that they have obv all
of a sudden just feels like even less
right because it's like I don't want to
cook tonight and I don't want like
there's a lot that feeds into that and
so part of me just wonders well I have
two thoughts a I'm like are you paying
your way through school that's a big
piece of the budget or are you going
into debt for school that not only adds
to debt but also stress so I just see a
real domino effect that seems to be
taking place and part of me wonders okay
do you guys need to pull back in some
way maybe you need to wait on school do
you know is it going to Roi the money
you think it's going to R like there's
so many things listen end of the day she
needs to call us and we need to help her
with her budget well and and I'm like
maybe it's just cuz we're on the Ramsey
Show watching this but I automatically
wouldn't be like how much are the car
payments how much are the de like
because that's always our thing but Jade
and again this may not be her situation
but statistically speaking could easily
fall into this scenario where there's
two $600 car payments in the driveway
and that's
$1,200 that's gone every single month
out of a paycheck so like there are real
things that could be happening behind
the scenes numbers wise that could
actually free her up I believe there are
I I would want I would want to know yeah
because if you're a registered nurse
You're making great money and if your
husband's working full-time and on top
of that working a side hustle um and if
in a state where the nurses don't make a
lot of money maybe you need to move MH
cuz that pay changes depending on where
you live yeah that's true so you know
like plenty of people all the time are
in jobs where uh theoretically they
should be earning more but they happen
to be in a place where they're just not
earning that much and so in this case I
feel like that could be at play but I
don't think that we heard this part
either in this clip but she also goes on
to say someone needs to do something
about this like and she starts talking
about the state the economy and she does
say like you don't like don't comment to
me about Trump and don't comment to me
about Biden but this is an economy
problem and someone needs to fix it
maybe if we all band together some
someone will fix this and someone will
hear us and come help us and I'm like if
you're to the point and this is not
criticism by the way like I'm saying
this as a person who I had that same
I've had a moment in my Jeep Liberty
with my husband when I told him to pull
the car over because this cannot go on
any further and I like seeing her cry
through Tears like I know what that is
yes and I I felt that but at the same
time you can either look at that as a
moment of someone come help us someone
needs to do something or go I need to do
something I can't keep living like this
my husband and I have to change like
where is that side of it yep yep it's
the complete flip of the perspective
that's a great Point that's a great
point you know because I'm not like I'm
not trying to be ugly or you know
incompassion but the fact is probably no
one's going to knock on your door and go
I'm here to save you like no one's going
to do that the government look they're
just going to keep on ticking and keep
on and I don't want you to keep living
like that so my guess is there's
probably not a real budget in place
because when there is a real budget you
can see like you said if those ratios
are off if you're like wow we're paying
50% for this 1100 square house you know
that's too much like you you you'll be
able to see those numbers
so yeah and I think you're right that
the idea that you have to advocate for
yourself no one is going to come save
you and that's true with your health
with your I mean like all these areas of
life not just money but you do get to a
point as a grownup where you're like oh
my gosh I felt this with my kids like at
the doctor or something I'm like oh
there's no one like it's me it's me
that's having to do this right so like
there's a moment where you have to be
the advocate for yourself and you're
advocate for Change and it's hard but
but but what she's feeling a lot of
people feel cuz it has been a hard year
you guys it's been a hard year but we
also want to look at the
[Music]
numbers hey guys it's Rachel Cruz it's
open enrollment season so it's a great
time to explore your healthc care
options for next year if you feel tied
down by your budget check out Christian
healthc Care Ministries chm is not
health insurance it's a faith-based
health cost sharing Ministry that has
helped members take care of nearly $1
billion do in healthcare costs chm is an
affordable alternative to insurance that
gives you the freedom and empowers you
to live out your values and you can join
at any time so find out more at
chministries.org SLB
[Music]
budget
you're listening to the Ramy show I'm
Jade warshaw this is Rachel Cruz and we
are taking your calls all hour give us a
call the number is 88 825 5225 we'd be
happy to hear from you let's go straight
to the phone lines where we've got Diana
from New York New York what's going on
Diana hi ladies I'm uh I'm well I'm just
outside of New York I'm in Connecticut
and um I am calling because my husband
and I we've been married 11 years we
have three amazing kids and uh we are
struggling um when we first got married
um we my husband really struggled um he
was laid off from a job just before our
wedding and um we uh it was unexpected
we were given the choice when we had a
wedding um I have super Savvy money
Savvy parents and um I just kind of
thought that uh you know the lifestyle
would somehow continue and uh we were
keeping up with the Joneses and we chose
the wedding over the down payment for
the house we were paying um you know uh
higher rents and it put us into a
position where um we made very bad
decisions with credit cards and we've
honestly been struggling uh just ever
since um income wise we're in a good
place right now um but uh we had two
kids um 11 months apart um within the
year of getting married and now we have
a little girl that's just about to turn
four um but we still have that credit
card debt from like uh you know six
seven years ago um
and uh we're in debt and we're living
paycheck to paycheck no matter how much
we make it just never seems to be enough
and um I just
really want to get smart with our money
and um I just feel like we're in this
big hole and we can't get out of it
because of our past and um we have about
uh $65,000 total worth of debt and um we
don't even touch 45,000 of that and
because we have poor credit um you know
we pay high interest rates for um our
cars and you know have all along and we
were just finally on the path to home
ownership and uh two months two years
ago two months before we closed at our
house my husband was laid off again um
and fortunately we never missed a beat
the paycheck he was uh reemployed within
two months okay um and ended up income
wise getting more but um at that point
we had no choice we were going to leaves
the house yeah so my mom fortunately
stepped in and took on the mortgage for
us um but uh so you're in the house now
we are in the house now theage yeah we
are we're safe um like I said my parents
fortunately um are what is the morgage
opposite of me can I get a few can I get
a few particulars from you what sure
okay how start with yeah go ahead yeah
how much are you guys making a year
um my husband makes about 125 and I make
about 25 and then we each have a few
occasional side hustles but um they're
seasonal so per month we bring in
anywhere between 96 and 9600 and 20 I
would say um I'm sorry 9600 and 10,500 a
month okay and can you go through and
list out each debt that you have that
totals up to
65,000 we have about 45,000 in personal
loan um we have 14,000 on a car um
fortun fortunately we were able to
before we um purchased our home we got
rid of his car because he went fully
remote during the pandemic okay um and
so we're one car family now I did get
into unfortunately a car accident um and
so the car that was paid off uh was
totaled um we probably made a mistake by
um you know buying a car worth more than
what we had
but we've got 14,000 in a car loan
remaining um and we put about uh 20,000
down when we bought the car two years
ago okay what other what other debt so
we've got the 45,000 personal loan
14,000 on a car yeah and then um about
5,000 um I would say in uh credit card
debt five and probably about 4,000 in
medical okay so you've got a really good
income this is good um the $65,000 of
debt and the one thing I also want to
ask you is your mortgage payment I
wanted to know how much your mortgage
payment is every month it's 2500 okay
not not a
problem I mean after we pay our bills I
mean it just seems like every month
anytime we get ahead I mean just like
with Home Oil you know once we get a
delivery we have we're back to zero and
um you know and plus we have poor
credits so we have nothing to you know
float us and well to be honest with you
when I look at your debt there's nothing
on here that I that I go oh my gosh
they've got they're drowning in payments
like you've got a lot of debt here but I
I also wonder if you guys' spending it
is where it's like where your spending
is out of control because I'm looking
I'm like okay a $4,000 medical debt
$5,000 in credit cards if you're paying
minimum payments and you're making
10,500 month that's not what's sinking
you right your $14,000 car is not what's
sinking you you know does that make
sense caus yeah I'm definitely the one
causing that and I recognize that um I
definitely have a hard time with not
keeping up with the Joneses and you know
I definitely um I'm definitely the
spender and um I'm definitely the cause
of I think a lot of that too um you know
we tend to uh eat out a lot cuz we're
busy with the kids and we're working and
uh paired with you know trips to
Marshalls and Homegoods and see that's
and that girl that's where the money's
going and I'm glad that you recogniz
that that it's you doing that the
question is what's going to happen to
change that because here's the thing you
could pay off all this debt but if you
don't get your spending under control
you're still going to spend away all the
money that you're supposed to be using
to do things like save and invest and
this is going to be an ongoing problem
for you even if you guys manage to pull
yourselves out of debt over time so
we've got to get a handle on that and
I'm guessing you're not on any real
budget it's kind of just pay the bills
and everything else is up for grabs kind
of thing yeah I try a budget but then
you know something happens or we need
home oil heating oil or you know um I
have a rare eye condition and you know
um a contact lens tears and I need a
contact lens that weirdly isn't covered
by the insurance company and it's just
like one thing after another it seems
and anytime we get a nest egg it just
seems like something pops up okay well
that's where your budget is going to
help you because if you if you're doing
a good budget you're going through every
single dollar and you're assigning it
with a purpose and you're choosing like
budgets include more things than just
rent mortgage utilities it includes
things like a trip to the eye doctor or
my contact lenses or a miscellaneous
category for things that you know
there's always something that pops up in
the month that's like I didn't know this
was coming but I've got this little you
know cushion here just in case and so
that's what a good budget boils down to
but I cannot stress it enough at the end
of the day it's the budget is a tool
it's something that we pick up and then
we wield it and use it and follow it
don't follow it right the budget doesn't
do the thing for you at some point you
do have to be like I'm I'm a grown woman
like I'm a grown woman absolutely who
has the ability to say yes or say no and
it sounds like you're kind of to that
point yeah di there's and you've said it
twice on this call so I'm going to just
kind of say what you've said is keeping
up with the Joneses keeping up with the
Joneses I know you know like you've said
that a few times and um you know money
we can we can talk about the numbers a
lot and that's what we're good at on the
show to help you solve that but what
Jade said earlier was exactly right that
until you Diana like there's something
there's there's something in there with
you and I can say this because I'm a
spender and I get it but I think being
able to pinpoint what is it in me that
is causing that what is it what is the
insecurity in me because it's not other
people's fault right they're living that
lifestyle but what we have to realize is
you know comparison will always be in us
I was talking to Dr John Zone about this
like there's a core part of humans that
comparison a real thing like even back
with our ancestors when they had to hunt
and they you know they had to figure out
things like you're constantly you know
sizing up things in your life and people
have to do that for survival so like
that is a part of who we are we're we
are naturally bent to look around and
see but the problem is is when we look
around and see and suddenly we say oh my
gosh I want what they have because what
they have is going to fulfill something
in me deep within me that's that's
missing and that's what I have to have
so there's there's some some
core um emotional parts of this Diana in
you specifically and in your story that
I would love for you just to dive in if
you hold on Austin will pick up because
I want to give you my book know yourself
know your money and love your life not
theirs it's about comparison mind too
give her mind too because there oh yes
and money is not a math problem Jade's
quick read so so this is so true for a
lot of people Diana but if you can if
you can get Diana under control and
actually start mapping out a budget I
think you guys are going to see a lot of
progress but it's hard but you can do it
you can do we're pulling for you Diana
this is the Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
Show
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships I am your host today Jade
warshaw joined by your other host today
Rachel Cruz and we are taking your calls
so give us a call the number is8 825
5225 we would love to hear from you and
I think it's really great Rachel that
we're both on the show together because
the fact of the matter is we both have
really great books out at this time uh
Rachel your first kids book ever which
is so exciting yes I'm glad for what I
have is available for pre-order now
that's super exciting or order now it's
not pre-order it's out oh it's out now
out and about I'm I'm reading this copy
all WR you're good no worries no you're
good you're good yes yeah it launched
beginning of November of this past month
so yeah it's um it's been so great great
and and talking to so many parents you
know talking about contentment with kids
is a really important conversation to
have so hopefully this book kind of
launches into that conversation I've
really enjoyed on your social seeing
everybody like post them reading it to
their kids and yes I love it love to see
so if you haven't gotten your copy get
your copy today it's out there it's a
great Christmas present now yours is
pre-order yes mine's still on pre-order
until December 5th okay it's coming soon
oh Jade I'm so excited for you and it's
really great because if you do order it
while it's on pre-order this the book
that I came out with is called money's
not a math problem and if you order it
now you get three months of every dollar
premium for free which is our budgeting
software that we talk about here all the
time and most people are trying to get
their money on track for the new year so
this is a great time to pre-order it so
that you get every dollar premium with
it so that's that order it today it's 10
bucks come on $10 go ahead and do that
let's go straight to the phone lines
where we've got Brenda in Dallas Texas
what's going on Brenda
hi um yes my dad he's in his 80s and I
have determined that he's been scammed
out of thousands of dollars by a fake
Publishing Company shoot um and so I
recently I persuaded him that it's a
scam uh but I still feel like he's very
vulnerable because they'll just keep
calling and keep calling with a new scam
and all of those things a year ago he um
got a call out of the blue to republish
one of his books and so they asked for
money up front and since then they've
just they they've even withdrawn without
permission from his account once they
got his account number oh wow so how
much money are we talking like um right
now it's almost 20,000 oh wow Brenda do
you guys have um contact information for
these people I mean like this is they're
stealing money it's this is illegal have
you contacted the police um no I haven't
really known what road to go down
legally what I have been doing is uh
like uh we cancelled his cards and got
new cards and we put in fraud
information with the with the bank and
um he recently agreed to add me to his
bank account um you know I mean he he
wants to leave a legacy for his family
and he's written these books and they're
wonderful books Christian teaching books
and
um it's just hard for him he's you know
he's not a child that I can tell what to
do he's a a grown adult and I don't want
to take
away um that but he's very vulnerable
he's easy to persuade and they just keep
calling with different
tactics wow so I guess my question
really is um because he's written
another book and they want and he didn't
tell them fortunately but it you know
it's ready to go and be published again
and he's basically told me can you find
me a safe place where I can publish this
book and in some respects I want to just
shut the door and say don't do that
anymore but writing is his his Outlet
well sure and when you say publishing
when you're saying publishing Brenda do
you mean just printing copies of the
book printing copies of the book and
like making it available on Amazon you
know yeah I mean that's would probably
check all the boxes for him right there
okay yeah and all of that's not like
crazy inexpensive I mean it's not crazy
expensive me you could you could do that
I mean it'll take some you know some
work on your end Brenda to help find a
printer and all of that but if that's
his wishes yeah he doesn't need to be
going through a third party unless you
think like oh my gosh it's like CS
Lewis's stuff or whatever that like he
actually could get signed to a publ a
legit publisher and do this I don't
think that's really what what he wants
to do necessarily well and I don't think
I would trust it at this point yeah no
no no I know I know so so yeah I think
you guys need to print yeah some some
copies and have a few boxes to give to
the grandkids I think you can probably
put it on Amazon I mean we do that kind
of stuff here at Ramsey well yeah and
the main thing that he's asked me is you
know
um can you find me somebody that can be
kind of like my agent and and in respect
to that I feel like if he had somebody
that he knew who was a legitimate
trustworthy
publisher then he would be less likely
to fall into the Trap of those that are
untrustworthy and pursuing him
constantly um thought about getting him
to change his phone number and
everything but um what if he got around
it kind of sounds like he's trying to do
a lot of this in a vacuum what if he got
around some clubs like and started uh
getting to know a group of writers to
where everybody's kind of looking at
each other's stuff and everybody's kind
of sharing contact information and it's
a little bit more of a trusted
environment where it's like have you
used this guy yeah I've used this guy
like you know how did you get your book
on Amazon this how I did it and it kind
of did a community approach as opposed
to I'm just like going down the Yellow
Pages and I'm going to pick a publisher
and I'm G like that does feel very you
don't know what you're going to get and
he's 80 years old Brenda I mean what's
your do you like like what do you think
his his motivation like what do you
think this is in him has he always
wanted to do this it's not to crush his
dream there's also a reality that you're
80 and you know what Me Not Be Your Big
Break right I mean I I don't I don't
understand if there's a unhealthy part
of him trying to be somebody is there
anything like that or is it just
genuinely he loves what he's writing
about and he wants it available for
people to read right like I'm like I
wonder what his motivation is in all of
it well and his first book that he wrote
is a kind of a teaching book on
Christian um
foundations and um the driving Point
behind creating the book was to use it
in a church setting and he did use that
for years and at some point he wanted to
take that material and put it together
in a book form and I think his desire
now comes from all that happened with
that years ago and so now he's written
another book that's similar to that and
yet another one um and he lost his wife
um my mom in January and uh he just
really needs something yeah a great
Outlet grab on to yeah give Focus yeah
so what I would do Brenda if I were you
is I would sit down with him and say Hey
Dad listen here's what's happened you
have been scammed out of almost $220,000
we can't keep doing this it's not wise
dad so any big money decision that's
happening anytime you want to spend
money will you just run it by me I just
want to talk through it make sure that I
can maybe like Run course for some of
this uh to be able to help you cuz I
want you to to you know if you have this
dream and have this content that you
want published and and out into the
world like we can get that done like we
can do that we also need realistic
expectations of what things are in life
and we don't want your legacy to go down
the drain financially by making bad
mistakes and so we I want to I want to
honor you in that and help you in that
as your daughter but also let's be wise
and any big financial decision dad like
let let team up with me and let's talk
it through together
[Music]
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need y refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snow ball and you can save
thousands of dollars to learn more about
this custom refinancing option and a
lumps some payoff option you could
qualify for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y refi.com
[Music]
Ramsey
[Applause]
[Music]
you're listening to the Ramy show I'm
Jade warshaw your co-host today joined
by Rachel Cruz your other co-host for
today give us a call the number Isle
5225 and if you are into Spotify you
probably received your like annual
Spotify wrapped results which is pretty
cool um where it'll just basically tell
you like what the top things you listen
to if you're into podcasts they'll tell
you the top podcasts you listen to on
their platform and it's been really cool
because since those results are in um
we've noticed that we're number one on a
lot of people's charts which is really
really cool so we want to know if the
Ramsey Show um made your Spotify wrapped
list and if it did let us know that
would be so great share your Spotify
wrapped results and tag us on social for
a chance to hear your name mentioned on
the show that's so cool and a lot of you
I know Rachel I've seen you repost some
I reposted some and so here are some of
the and you're on the like main image
there we could have three people and so
it's Dave Jade and George right look
luckily they got my good side I'm so
excited a great picture here are some of
the usernames of people who have shared
uh that we were in their top podcast um
so hopefully I get these right guys okay
we have Nicole M Nicole m bitched that's
her username um this one is Jade PAB
Broadbent there you go no relation to
myself um Blake perter Aliyah Aaliyah
Fitz uh Chrissy
305 Katie Irene 183 which some people
might remember her on the show from
being the horse girl that George said
she had to sell her horse um Ali kins um
I'm gonna try this one but it's not GNA
be good toxic Kitty toxic Kitty I don't
like the sound of that then we got here
Morgan roarer love it guys keep sharing
your playlist We will say your names on
the live radio Podcast and hopefully
we'll say them right so if I didn't get
it right please believe me I tried still
share them with us whether it's you know
in the comments or you know the little
paper airplane on Instagram we'd love to
see that all right Rachel should we go
to the phone lines yes let's do it we
got Jake in Cincinnati Ohio how can we
help
Jake hey thanks for taking my call um
follow the baby steps everything's great
for people that are listening first time
they definitely do work so follow them
of course love it um question I'm a
school teacher so um we're at the point
now we're looking at the investing of
the baby steps and 14% of my income goes
straight into like our school's pension
plan we don't really have a choice
through the state and I was wondering if
the advice changes to people like me
that don't really get to control that do
I just do an extra 1% outside of that or
what your guys advice would be yeah so
with a pension we usually say that you
want to take that percentage and just
cut it in half so 50% so 7% of it's fine
I would then fund my own 7% because the
thing with a pension is you don't have
really a choice on where that money is
invested and the powerful thing about
retirement investing yeah is that you
have the ability to look and to choose
the mutual funds and all of that so we
want more of that on your side so Jake
yeah with your um that 14% yeah I would
drop it you know in your head 7% so that
means you'll have 8% that you're going
to want to invest to get to that
15% in retirement so that's that's what
I would do does that make sense for you
Jake yeah perfect just 8% into a Roth
IRA max it out and all the from there
it's perfect yeah great job Jake awesome
well done well done thank you so much
for the call all right let's moving on
along we've got Andy who's in Tulsa
Oklahoma what's going on
Andy thank you very much for taking my
call I'm uh I'm calling today for sure
advice helped with my 25-year-old
daughter who uh a year ago had $3,000 in
the bank and her own business but she
walked away from that and went to
another state to join a fellow that she
had met up with and uh unfortunately two
weeks ago she came back home uh the the
relationship went poorly she's down to
$150000 to her name um she has broken a
lease at an apartment which she's going
to 60004 and a credit card that she has
6,500 balance on both in her name only
because he had horrible credit oh those
we're just going to deal with we're just
going to deal with those yeah he talked
her into putting everything in her name
Alone um the worst one is at age 25 a
major car company gave them a car loan
uh they bought a car for 66,000 they ran
it up to 880,000 by adding on warranties
etc etc they borrowed about $70,000 from
this car again in her name only and
she's stuck with this thing she doesn't
have the money she can't uh take the
apartment on her own she can't own this
car on her own she simply doesn't have
the wherewithal it's an 84 Monon loan at
99.59% and the total amount is 880,000
was purchased for 80 there's a 70 owing
on it and unfortunately I booked it and
the Kelly Blue on the car is about 35 to
40 as a private party o so yeah horribly
upside down as her dad I'm saying look
take your lumps pay the apartment pay
the credit card but let's turn this car
back into the bank and just take the hit
on your credit report you'll like a
voluntary repossession is that what
you're suggesting that's that's what I'm
thinking it'll be one event not many and
she can explain it and she'll just have
to live it down but there's no L way she
can even sell the car for Kelly Blue
Book value and then make up the
difference she like I said a year ago
she had $30,000 and now she's down to,
1500 before we do a voluntary
repossession cuz that that is an atom
bomb like let's be honest about that
that's that's going to follow her around
in a similar way that even a bankruptcy
would for quite a while so 70,000 I mean
the other debt that she has the $6,000
lease thing the 6,500 in credit
cards that's not like
something she can't easily overcome and
the $70,000 car is a lot and there may
be some other options there but let's
talk about her income because I know she
got out of of this relationship but
she's still able to earn an income so
what what does that look like for her
what's her profession like can we get
some numbers in that in that area so a
year ago she had her own business doing
uh eyelashes eyebrows and at one point
she was earning more than I am um but
but she walked away from all of that and
to be perfectly honest I have no
understanding whatsoever how these two
were making money they do they were
doing
online
coaching uh for train for physical
training and Fitness and Nutrition Etc
but honest influencing and stuff okay
right and I clearly doesn't work okay so
she's not earning anything right now
she's not earning anything right now so
Andy what um and where's the guy in all
of this she left town but is he so she
left yeah so she's come back home now
two weeks ago um it was it it ended up
abusive both mental and physical wow I'm
sorry so there's there's that side of it
yeah for sure which is real he's yeah
he's back in the state that that they
were in um but I heard he's mobile I
don't know he's gone to the wind okay
okay so he's out yeah there's so there's
we're we're starting Clean Slate without
him um so yeah Andy I think I think for
her I think one of the best gifts that
you could give her especially
considering what she just walked out of
is any level of confidence that she can
have back in herself because when you're
in a relationship like that for she was
in there for a year I think you said I
mean that just that that tears down who
you are as a person and so there's
something about this is not the fix all
but for her to go back to something she
knows she's good at so the eyelashes
that you know everything that CA IC
stuff that she was doing um if there's a
shop if there's a um you know some some
type of business that she doesn't own I
don't think she's in a place to start
her own thing that she could go and just
start working you know even if it's 30
hours a week but that there's some
consistency in earning an income and
we're not going to be in a rush all
these numbers are here we're going to
work on we're going to work through them
but there's part of her building back
that dignity and that confidence in who
she is and I think her living Liv with
you guys for a bit I think is is a
really wise thing um especially from
what she's just come out of I'm okay
with that I'm 100% And So yeah so I
would say like Jade said the the atom
bomb of the car repossession I almost
would just try to sell it for that
40,000 take that
$30,000 hit take you know so she's going
to have a loan of that she's going to
have a lot of debt here yeah she's got
to get a loan for that difference yes
and but then there's going to be some
some years of working through this but
obviously I'd rather be in this
situation than where she was um but
there's just some things that she's
going to have to really slow walk
financially but I also think it's
possible for her I mean I really do I
think it's going to be a long road ahead
but I think that there there is a
way you're a good dad this is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free seey blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 40% off everything sitewide
go to blinds.com for more
[Music]
[Applause]
information
hey what's going on everybody you are
listening to the Ramsey Show hey thanks
for listening to the Ramsey Show um and
if you like this show we'd always love
it if you like subscribe and share it
with somebody who you think could
benefit from it I'm your host Jade
warshaw and I'm joined by Rachel Cruz
today as we take your calls give us a
call the number Isle 8825 5225 and we'll
talk about the things that are
concerning you everything that relates
to to your life and your money it could
be relationships with your kids it could
be your your career it could be the
holiday season that is upon us Rachel
and um I was talking to James during the
break because I saw a article that said
25% of Americans are still paying off
Christmas from last year oh my gosh
while
simultaneously plan on spending more
this year this year just keeps going
keeps going and so I find that to be
very interesting so Rachel I'm going to
hit you with a couple of facts and I
want you to react and let's get into
this so the stats say that on average
Americans are going to spend
$875 on Christmas and that kind of
shakes out to a little over 600 on like
gifts for like immediate family
co-workers then another around 200 on
like decorations like miscellaneous
things and then another hundred on just
kind of like random oh like that guy
over there needed a gift kind of thing
what do you think about that number uh
it doesn't sound like terrible to me it
doesn't sound I thought it would be more
yes I would have thought at least 1,200
in my head I thought it'd be over a
thousand for the average like but also
all of that that's not just Christmas
gifts this is like the whole holiday
season this is the holiday season yeah
and part of me goes okay
875 couldn't we have like stacked up a
little money throughout the year uhhuh
to make that happen I know that's right
that's right think about that guys okay
so then I read this that
48% of Americans start
shopping before the end of October so oh
wow people get started early and I'm
like okay like that spreads it out a
little bit right through at least three
months yeah but they're putting on
credit cards yes it's going into going
on to debt okay so this is the kicker
here's the kicker 60 61% of people have
said and this is very current like as of
October 61% of people have said hey
we're living paycheck to paycheck um
four out of 10 people are saying man we
are worse off this year than we were
last year so basically they're saying
life is hard right now finances are hard
right now but when asked they still plan
on spending more this year than last
year that for me and I'm like wait a
minute wait a minute what's happenening
and then they come through with the stat
that says 74% of Amer say they feel
stressed about their money I'm like what
is happening you're making this Choice
yes oh my gosh see that's what's funny
is I'm like and it's such a human
behavior thing that it's like once you
have your mind set to something you're
like oh I'm going to do it regardless of
what the other numbers are saying I'm
going to choose to continue following
this plan and you're just like wait no
no no no you can stop right now you can
stop and pivot well Ross on Friends with
the counts he's like pivot we can all
pivot our plans if your numbers are not
adding up with this and if you're still
paying Christmas from last year yeah let
me tell you what I'm hearing in my heart
that I I know that I know someone is
saying I know someone is like Jade the
year has been so hard I feel like I
can't spend money on anything I feel
like I just need a little Joy Rachel
like I I can't give up Christmas too
like I can't this let me just go hard on
Christmas and then when January 1st
comes I'll get back on track and please
Rachel don't take Christmas from me I
got to get my gifts come on I got to get
and what's funny is the gifts let's just
be honest some I'm sure really great
sentimental things yeah probably a lot
of crap for the kids that they're
they're going to play with for two days
and then they're moving on to the next
thing as you pointed out yesterday Jade
adults don't need gift shipping gifts
around to Aunt Rita who if Aunt Rita at
quote Jade needs the blender Aunt Rita
can buy the blender that's right so so
really I might it's either
obligation uh it's because you just
always have done it yeah uh I mean like
right there's a lot of this in play when
you could actually say okay let's just
stop let's just stop and
reassess what's what's really happening
and we can get our kids some things but
it doesn't have to be that much it
doesn't have to be that what would
happen if you got like a family gift
that like the whole like a ping pong
table like something that it's one gift
like you don't have to spend four and
$500 but it's one gift that the whole
family canat really enjoy it brings
everybody together like what would that
look like especially if you're in debt
and you're really trying you know you're
still paying off Christmas from 2022 or
Beyond like I just feel like there's
ways that we can pull back and go like
do we want to stay on this hamster wheel
that's it yes keep creating debt and or
do we want to just do cuz really usually
it only takes one year to like put that
stake in the sand and be like all right
this this year is going to be different
and you can get so much traction yes
from just one time drawing that line and
be like this year we're not do and
there's something about lived
experiences that I think bring us back
to what we've always done right it's
like it's I'm we know it we're
comfortable with it it's just what what
we do and so we just go back into what
we do and to your point if you change
something different this year for
Christmas like you pull way back or you
stop giving gifts out to Aunt Rita
whatever it is and you live through it
it gets to be February March and you
think oh okay everyone's okay yeah
everyone's fine we all survived and I
could repeat that again right so like
it's almost like you have to go through
the the actual action of it to to to
assure yourself you're going to be okay
yeah and everyone else is going to be
okay that's a word that's a word Rachel
cuz it really is like it's like a new
cycle like when something's really big
in the news and it's like the only thing
anybody's reporting on and then two
three weeks later it's crickets you
never hear about it again yes and I feel
like Christmas is that like right now
it's like Christmas there's only two
paychecks till Christmas and by the way
there is only two paychecks till
Christmas and it's like the only thing
we can think about but you're so right
on December
26th no one cares I know it's over yep y
December 26th it's over and you can go
wow okay like that is over now like it
didn't matter honestly and call me
cheesy but I'm being for real I'm like
even this past
Thanksgiving I'm like and I know
Thanksgiving doesn't have gifts and all
of it but I'm like when I look back with
my kids I'm like the memories we have we
took bikes to an empty parking lot from
a high school down the road road bikes
around the parking lot cuz Carol Canal
Rider bike um you know we went on a hike
we did puzzles I forced my kids to do
puzzles cuz I'm 80 years old and I love
puzzles so we did like Christmas puzzles
uh we watched home alone too uh we saw
my family we had a friends giving
everyone brought appetizers and stuff
and we all you know had a great night
and played a game and you know what mean
I'm like you look back and it's like
that's the good life 100% it's not all
the crap that you clean out of your
playroom 18 months later that's all you
know what I mean like yes and so there's
something to be said yes stuff is fun we
are not against stuff on this show okay
so like yes Santa's going to be bringing
a new bike for one of the children and
like we're going to be having some fun
stuff this Christmas but yet like what
do we all remember we remember the T the
time spent and I don't want to seem like
a Hallmark movie cheese of it but it's
just true you guys it's true so that is
true don't go into debt like it don't
stop just stop it's unnecessary go ride
bikes in an empty parking lot with your
kids and have an afternoon I mean might
be the first time you've ever done that
cuz Rachel what you're describing that
is a mindset and it for many that is a
complete mindset shift like I was on a
webinar the other day um about budgeting
and we were talking about look if your
Christmas budget doesn't allow for it
you may have to cut back and some of the
people in the chat were saying oh we're
not having Christmas this year and like
oh I guess that does it for Christmas
this year I guess we can't have it and
I'm like cuz it equals gifts cuz yeah
that's what I'm saying that's a mindset
shift cuz for a lot of people Christmas
is gifts and we've never had it any
other way we don't know what it looks
like to not have a stack you know
everybody post that stack on Instagram
where they're all like stacked up the
wall and all the wrapping paper the same
and I'm like whose life looks like that
but did I tell you my story about this
last year tell me we I did okay I did
that okay I saw everyone posting their
pictures I thought it was sweet and we
were going to bed that Christmas Eve you
know uh I think Santa had come and you
know the Christmas tree was on it just
like it was a sweet picture for me and I
took a picture and I did put it on
Instagram I just said happy Christmas
you know Merry Christmas Eve everyone
hope you're having a great timeas yeah I
hope you're having a great Christmas of
your family Jade the amount of comments
underneath that was like I'm so glad you
practice a minimal a minimal Christmas
Rachel minimalism is at the crew all
this stuff I was like no oh I didn't
think we did oh my gosh Winston did we
so obviously we did good it made me feel
good we because there wasn't a ton but I
feel like we got good gifts for our kids
anyways it just made me laugh cuz I was
like Winston who knew it we were
minimalists and didn't that didn't even
know it and it was a great Christmas so
you don't need gifts to have a great
Christmas this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm Jade warshaw
joined by Rachel Cruz give us a call the
number is8 825 5225 let's go directly to
the phone lines where we've got Monica
in San Jose California hey Monica what's
going
on hi um thank you for taking my call so
I am calling because my husband and I
bought our first home in the Bay Area in
September um I can go into the financial
details of you know how it all went down
but essentially it was for 1.19
million um what
1.19 okay okay we were able to put
550,000 down wow
nice yeah
so again if it's helpful I can go into
all the financial details of like what
the mortgage is all what's your
question the question is that we hate
the house oh what yeah what changed oh
no yeah we're really unhappy shoot
why it's just it's not a great great
layout for our lifestyle um not a lot
can be done to change it um it's a town
home so you know there's restrictions on
what you can do with an HOA and not only
that it's a three-story town home so
it's it's just a big issue around layout
primar you know that going in like you
didn't buy it side un
scene yeah I know um we we did know it
the we you know we were firsttime home
buyers and I think we really didn't
spend enough time on thinking about the
home we were really concerned about
whether it was a good financial decision
and we spent a lot of time thinking
about that yeah and yeah and you know
this is like a very competitive area for
Real Estate so um we just we really
wanted to be home buyers and like at the
end of the day the question is um you
know we're already here it's already
done is it worth it for us
to take a loss and try to get out of it
as soon as
possible
or should we try to stay for do you feel
like it's going to be a
loss well like my husband is is
particularly very unhappy here and like
I just feel life is really short and
it's causing a lot of stress and like
financially get if you sold it why would
it be at a
loss well the the the um value of the
home is already dipped since we
purchased it what's it at
now and also of course the seller fee
for you know working with a realtor all
of that is going we would definitely
take a loss it's a matter of how much of
a loss so we're just trying to think
through doesn't makes sense to stick it
out like how long should should we try
to stick it out before trying to sell it
I gotta be honest like part of me like
I'm hearing what you're saying and I can
tell that it's really bothering you um
it's bothering your husband more than
you Monica and that's my that's a little
bit of my question is that he's unhappy
and he's short and he's not but like I
the reasons and look feel free to
elaborate but like people call in and
they're like oh the guy upstairs is
smoking weed or you know my neighbors
are violent or there there was a murder
in you know across the street like
there's those are the Reon that I'm like
yes you need to move immediately but
when somebody's like oh I just bought a
$1.19 million house and I just don't
like the
layout I I'm struggling with that I'm
not going to lie is there something else
that we're is it far from work is there
a big commute like is there something
else that's really weighing into this
that you're not
saying well you know we moved from a
home that was in the same community that
we were renting and it was fully
upgraded and we missed the opportunity
to buy that home like with without
Realtors being involved so we you know
it could have been like a directly
buying from the owner
situation and so I think like that's
really Weighing on us and comparing this
home to that is really hard because that
was an upgraded home this is not and
we're going to have to put some money
into this home to make it as comfortable
as that home was it's also on a busier
street so it's really loud and we have a
baby and she's often being WC up due to
the well a sound machine can solve that
we can just get one of those white noise
machines I'm so can I I'm just being
flat out honest with you I I don't know
that this is a reason for you guys to
move I think this is a bit of um and I'm
not saying you can't move eventually but
to take a fin L does it make
sense yeah yeah it it doesn't Monica I
mean from the from a you call into a
financial type show and so we do look at
the numbers of this and um yeah I mean
it's not I mean if you guys have the
money and you find something better and
you guys just shake hands with each
other and say we're going to take the
loss we're going to call it stupid tax
we shouldn't have bought in the first
place we're going to go find something
we want you guys can but financially
it's not smart and what's what what you
have to understand too Monica is that
there's a there there's a level with
this discontentment that can be
legitimate like I get that but also that
level of contentment and who you guys
are still moves with you and so that is
one conversation I would make sure to
have with you and your husband to say
okay you know we're moving because we
don't like the house and no house is
going to be perfect and the next house
we come to is not going to solve all of
our problems it's not going to be the
thing that fixes everything in our lives
and um I don't know does that make sense
like there's a level of that
discontentment that I'm hearing and that
can follow
you it's just it's it's more so that
when someone is deeply unhappy like
every single day and it's impacting your
well-being to the point that it's that's
it though mon should be doing that it
shouldn't be impacting him because
there's three stories like do you know
what I'm like that like like that's
where I'm likeo there's some stuff
happening that's probably more than just
the house in his in his life and what's
happening I mean like if if you're
really that unhappy because of a layout
of a house then you're you're an unhappy
person like there's something else going
on yeah I I second that I think there's
something I mean my husband and I moved
from South Florida to here Monica and
before we moved we had done everything
we had completely renovated our house
made it exactly the way we wanted but
then we moved for a job and we moved
here and our house is nice but it's not
upgraded it's not it's not the way it
was and I could easily be like oh man
like that other house was so much better
and now we're gonna have to you know
renovate this one and $1 1.1 million you
know like there's there's just some part
of that where you do have to take a beat
and be like well we have a great home
and it's going to take a while to get it
where we want it or we're going to have
to live in this home until we can afford
to move to the next home yeah so I guess
the question is how long do we need to
hold it before it makes sense to sell it
I our rule our rule of thumb is five
years for a house to kind of ride
through the market well we tell people
to buy if you're going to buy a house
make sure you're in it for at least 5
years that's usually a good average
amount of time for the market to kind of
go up and down all of that but again and
we're in a weird Market you know and
Monica hear us say like and I always
give people this out on this show that
you're a grownup like if you guys decide
we're going to go take a $80,000 hit yes
then we're going to do that right you're
the one who has to sleep at night but
but but just hear hear us say though
there is other stuff happening that's
causing in this unhappiness that will
follow you and and and that would be
more of my concern if we can't be
content as a family of where we
are and again I understand like oh the
cabinets are old like I I get that
things aren't upgraded I understand that
I understand that but but the but the
the environment of the emotional
environment of the family and of the
home the fact that it is so tilted right
now because of a layout in three
stories that worries me I don't like
that so there's a part of me that kind
of wants ought to stick it out figure
out figure out what the real problem is
yeah to have to deal kind of what's with
with with with where you guys are and I
know that's stressful as a wife and all
of it um yeah you're in a hard spot
Monica and I'm so sorry so again if you
guys choose to you know I pulled $80,000
out of the air I don't know what it'll
be then y'all can and you can move but
um but if you're asking from a financial
standpoint five years is usually a good
rule if th from a time frame perspective
well it also makes me wonder I'm like
okay if they sell this house at a hit
they're not going to they bought what
they could afford so what are the
chances that they're really going to be
able to get anything better than what
they already have now you know what I
mean so they could I mean a better
layout maybe maybe but it might not be
fully
upgraded I don't know I'm sorry Monica
deeper issues are involved here 100%
that does it for this hour of the ramsy
show join us for the next
[Music]
hour
la
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships I am your host Jade
warshaw joined by your other host
bestselling author host of the the
Rachel Cruz show Rachel Cruz I almost
said the Ramsey crw Show great very s
the same all the same we're taking calls
about your life and money so give us a
call the number is 8825 5225 and we
would be happy to talk with you again
anything that has to do with your life
your money Christmas gifts um whatever
you can think of we will talk about it
as long as it has to do with life and
money so give us a call we'll go
directly to the phone lines here with
Dorothy in Boston Massachusetts what's
going on
Dorothy hey Jade hi hi
Rachel um my question today is where
would be a really good place to start
when someone knows little to nothing
about
investing I love that
question how invest it is me I'm asking
for a friend um yeah right here no it's
great you know I let me just tell you
what I did um I knew that I wanted to
work with a smart Vestor Pro or like
work with a professional but I also
wanted to kind of have like a baseline
of knowledge going in so that I could
follow them in the conversations and
also have an idea of what I wanted
because I didn't want to go into it with
this idea of like okay you just tell me
what to do right I wanted to right learn
and understand it and so for me a lot of
that was I started listening to shows
like this and digging into that content
and on our website ramsy solutions.com
we have so many articles on investing
and all these things that you can really
sort through and I think that that's a
really great resource and then I just
spent time doing my own research and
then I called up a smart festor Pro and
I kind of let them know hey here's what
I'm thinking um the the financial plan
that I follow talks about investing
across four types growth growth and
income aggressive growth and
international and they talk about
putting 25% into each one I agree with
that you know and I I just really
started that conversation and I let them
know hey I'm open to learning I just
want to understand how we're investing
and how we're doing this and so that's
how I started um does that is that
ringing is that pushing any buttons for
you yes it is I'm not quite there yet um
to baby step four four we start yeah
yeah so but I just want to have like
some basic knowledge IDE yeah yes so
when someone's like S&P 500 or whatever
it is yeah totally okay so here's just
kind of a let's just do a quick like
High L investing school for you Dorothy
I love it okay so when it comes to
investing we always we have the rule we
call it the kiss rule keep it simple
stupid that's what we say keep keep it
simple Great rule yes because people get
very deep into the weeds of stuff and
they're all like trying to do all this
fancy stuff so keep it simple so yes you
mentioned the the S&P 500 the Dow Jones
when you turn on the news and you see
the big chart right with all the stuff
right so picture I'm like that's right y
y so what you're looking at is just
basically the values of these companies
and so with the S&P 500 is the top 500
largest companies and so you're going to
have apple you're going to have Ford
Motor Company you're have Target I mean
you you're you're going to have 500 of
the largest companies and when you buy
into those companies you buy into the
market right you can do s&p500 which is
not to get too complicated like the
index index funds um you can go into the
stock Market but basically what you're
doing is you're buying a small portion
of these companies when you go and buy a
stock MH now we recommend Dorothy people
can buy single stocks where you put all
of your money in apple or you put all of
your money in Target or all of your
money in American Airlines we don't
recommend that so some people's strategy
is they go and they and they buy
individual stocks and they put their
money and hope that that you know a few
of these companies do really well what
we teach Dorothy is to invest in mutual
funds so mutual funds are 90 to 200 of
those stocks in One Fund okay and so
okay that's going to help spread your
money out so you're not in single stocks
so that's kind of how the market the the
basis of that now we can Branch off into
retirement investing so you're going to
hear things like a
401k which most companies offer their
employees and they'll do a match so if
you put in 3% of your income Dorothy the
company will match 3% or some companies
it's 4% 5% 6% now when you're opening a
401k then you have a choice when you put
when you the money that they have where
is that money going and that's what Jade
is talking about is actually taking your
money and buying mutual funds with it
now the specific mutual funds are the
four types that she talked about you
know that got you know she that's that's
pretty deep in there uh in the details
of it but that's the 401K there's a
there's a IRA a traditional IRA and a
Roth IR
which is another vehicle for investing
and again you can open that account but
the money you have in that account you
want to actually invest and that's where
a smartvestor pro can help you um and
then another term to remember Dorothy is
Roth Roth is your friend r o t h Roth
means it's after tax dollars so it's
after you've paid taxes on your income
your income hits your checking account
you use that money to go and fund a Roth
IRA which the great thing about that
since it's after tax dollars that means
all the growth that's going to happen
compound interest in that in that
account is taxfree because you've
already paid taxes yes which is
beautiful so whenever you see Roth we
want that we want Roth IRA versus
traditional and if your company offers a
Roth 401k you take that too now again
it's after tax dollars so you're going
to feel it a little bit more it kind of
hurts a little bit more cuz 100% you've
paid the taxes and you're like oh um but
again that's kind of just I I don't want
to confuse you but that's kind of just
the basics you know that's very clear
that we look at but I would sit down
with a smartvestor pro what um Jade said
if you go to Ramsey solutions.com you
can find one in your area and if you're
anywhere near Boston there should be
multiple yes and sit down and talk to
them set up meetings and interview each
of them and kind of figure out who you
like just from a personal standpoint who
you enjoy who's going to teach you um
because this is yeah you want someone in
your Corner because it can get really
granular really fast right and you want
somewhat of an understanding but you
also have to know that these people you
know they do this day in and day out so
there's a level of trust you have with
them too in this process yeah and I also
want to encourage you or anybody else
listening people rarely understand it in
one take like they they you know what I
mean like I had a buddy come visit me
and she was like Jade explain this
explain this Roth IRA thing to me one
more time and you rarely get it in the
first try it's like I I remember the
first time I was like wait a minute wait
what now and it's like you you want to
go back and listen to it again so go
back and listen to this call again like
I said dig into some of those articles
make sure you're setting up time to talk
with these people because it takes a
minute for you to really understand it
cuz like Rachel said and it's true it
does get granular very quickly and it's
like okay but once I finished my Roth
IRA then what do I do next and then if I
have more money where do I go next and
so before you know it you're really
going down the line on this and you want
to make sure that you do have a clear
understanding because these are your
hard-earned dollars yeah and and and
Dorothy and for anyone listening that
Babys set 4 is 15% of your income into
retirement so retirement is going to be
your 401k at work or
403b and a and a Roth IRA um so those
are the two main ones there's other
things like an HSA and different things
if you max out those other two that are
options and we talk about that here at
Ramsey but for most people listening
always remember it's your 401k and Roth
IRA 15% of your income that goes into
those that's right all right this is the
Ramsey
[Music]
show
you are listening to the ramsy show and
I want to let you guys know that our
ramsy Solutions Cyber Monday sale is
extended so if you thought the savings
were over you were wrong you can still
go on and get some of our lowest prices
of the Year all week long you can get
meaningful gifts for your family and
friends as low as $ I'm talking about
Audi books I'm talking about every
dollar premium gift cards for $4 $9.99
that's amazing you can even get things
like Financial Peace University our 9we
series to help you learn about money you
can get that for as low as
$59.99 there are gifts for everyone you
can find things for your kids you can
find things to set and accomplish your
goals I'm talking about the Ramsey 2024
goal planner which is just
$44.99 and by the way the content in
that was designed by Rachel Cruz sitting
to my right Dr John delone and myself so
it's a great planner to help you work on
your faith relationships and finances
through all the teachings that we give
you throughout the year so that's a big
one and honestly one of my favorites the
Rachel Cruz wallet is available and many
colors I think the champagne color is my
favorite one Rachel if I'm being oh and
a brand new edition Navy do we did a
Navy this year I know loveful too what
I'm saying guys is you've got to get
online and shop our weeklong Cyber
Monday sale it's at ramseys
solutions.com
sstore got to go pick that up wow all
right let's talk from neighborly decom
here for a moment so our question of the
day is brought to you by neighborly your
hub for Home Services now if you need
work done on your home your yard but
don't know where to start or who to
trust I'm telling you neighborly is the
answer find all the help you need at
neighborly
docomomo for this Scrooge mom on a
budget from Ohio she requested this name
she she said please address the topic of
Christmas gifts for teachers I hear my
adult children talk about the cost of
gift cards etc for their children's
teachers I raised four children they had
multiple teachers every year for
specials you know PE speech music art
playground supervisors cafeteria workers
Home Room Etc uh any given Christmas I
could have dropped hundreds of dollars
on 30 plus teachers and support staff
alone they are hardworking professionals
and I'm trying to understand how this
all got started and why it has gotten
out of hand I am more inclined to get a
Christmas gift for those working on
Christmas Day interesting Fair um yeah
so I I don't know where this quote
unquote got out of hands um I don't know
and I think it's a I think it's a really
personal thing that whatever you choose
to do what your budget allows but I do
think the expectation of just people in
general doesn't need to be your
expectations you have to set your own
for your own household and
Jade what I have found um with majority
of my kids majority of years a lot of
the room mom or someone will actually
you'll venmo her money and she'll get a
big gift from the class oh that's great
so that works out really well um which
is very nice now I will say this is one
my our teachers I will I do kind of go
big on my kids like specific teachers so
like the kindergarten teacher and Amilia
has third grade she has two teachers so
I will I'm like I cuz I just appreciate
them a lot and again we have the we our
budget it's something that I plan and I
do so that is one area of life that I
feel like I'm more I probably I may
spend more on a teacher than my like my
parents oh my God because look but
that's your choice yeah and I want to
and I genuinely do and I don't do it for
all of them you know um even though
there's so many people that help out and
all of that but I I think it's it has to
be in your budget that's right and the
expectations for your family not letting
everyone else set it but I think the the
group gift is always a great great it's
a great idea I like that look I hope
that's what happens with my son's
kindergarten class because I haven't
heard anything yet but I'm like what do
we do I and I know teachers I've heard
from them they don't want candles and
all that please no candles so gift cards
is a thing right so if you go and yeah
spend you know 20 bucks or whatever to
get them a great gift card at Target or
they're going to appreciate that and and
can I just say for the people get them a
gift card that they really can choose
what it spin on like Visa gift cards
Target gift cards Target and Walmart
gift cards I think are fine because
there's so much or like Amazon gift
cards CU there's so much to choose from
but don't come in here with like a
Subway Gift card because everybody
doesn't like Subway or even Starbucks I
just feel like yeah yeah he yes I just I
I think that I speak for the teachers
when I say let them kind of choose their
own gift if you're going to do a gift
card make sure you make it a generalized
yes and it is for me it's a you know
it's a profession that I mean and
everyone knows that they're not paid but
they should be paid for the amount of
hours and work and what they're doing
they're literally teaching the Next
Generation how I mean I I can't I'm not
a homeschool mom I mean I I would be
terrible terrible teacher I mean Emilia
is bringing home Common Core math now
and I'm just like I literally have no
idea what you're like I can't do this I
don't know what you're doing I'm scared
so it's yeah and so I really do
appreciate good teachers and we've been
so blessed our kids school I mean every
teacher we've we have just loved I mean
they're just wonderful so yep teachers
out there to all you teachers listening
and watching or if you know a teacher
send them this clip cuz Jade and I both
as moms greatly appreciate good teachers
cuz man it's a lot of work they deal
with a lot I mean I would say at the
very least if if your holiday budget if
you're like look on the holidays I'm
stretched to my like stretched to the
core make make it a point to contribute
at least at some point throughout the
year that or like do baked goods like do
do like a loaf of bread with a with a
letter like some level of of
appreciation doesn't have to be through
a present some level of appreciation is
they all need it yes Christmas or like
just make it part of your Rhythm because
they need that stuff ooo love it that's
good sorry Scrooge mom we had to we had
to debunk you on that one all right
let's go straight to the phone lines
we've got Deborah in Dayton Ohio what's
going on
Deborah hi I'm looking at starting
building a uh real estate property
portfolio cool and I'm ready to do like
probably the baby step I'm very I would
say conscientious about being in debt
okay um I own my own home we don't have
a payment there we own another home
that's no payment but that's getting
prepared to go on the market for a rent
here for probably around 16 to 1700 a
month okay um I do own another smaller
property that I purchased waiting for
that refi at 6% and I owe about a 70k on
that
um my payments are about 600 and rents
for about
975 just to get somebody in there
quickly I did that and um so s there the
only the debt that we only are carrying
now is um a truck that we got at 0%
interest and that was like for our
future future uses and um that is
probably about 1,200 a month what's the
full
amount no oh how much did it cost yeah
oh we went day 95
95,000 yeah yeah we've been getting some
expensive cars this
show um we like cars we like motorcycles
what else do you have our passion what
other just
curious four motorcycles four motorcyc
are they all paid for yes yes okay
purchase Range Rover purchased fully in
cash how much do you guys make a year
debborah a van no purchase
I just wait until I have it or we paid
it off okay um so together um I have a
escort set up for myself and my husband
makes you know 110 I make maybe
somewhere similar because I'm on a
commission so you guys make
220,000 a year yeah roughly 220 to
250 okay 250 okay so we purchased a
house a year and a half ago remodeled it
and um it took about 50k to get it up to
what we want so I'm very happy um I was
very conscientious to stay to where
probably I could sell it now for 350 you
may have to come on with your question
because we're right up against the clock
so how can we help yeah my question is I
have probably 60k in my in my um account
so I could pay off that little rental
property I could pay off the 0% interest
but I really want to maybe purchase have
money to purchase another small rental
okay so if I were in your shoes if I
were in your shoes I would pay off the
final rental that you have because your
primary residence is paid for in cash
home number two is paid for in cash if
you can pay off home rental home number
three I would definitely do that and I
would not buy any more real estate
without paying cash for it also you guys
have too much stuff that's tied up too
much money tied up in vehicles that are
going down in value I would seriously
consider scaling back on buy buying
things with motors I it sounds like you
have too manyi as it is this $95,000
truck really really deeply deeply bother
me but you guys have got a high net
worth so I'm not that concerned about it
get it paid off as soon as possible this
is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
you are listening to the ramsy show
there are only two more paychecks till
Christmas so help let us help take the
calls about your life and your money and
what you're doing with your money not
only now but into the new year so you
can get on a plan where you're actually
making traction and paying off debt and
saving money we want to help you do that
so give us a call the number is 8825
5225 I'm Jade she's Rachel we will take
your call let's go straight to the phone
lines where we've got Mary from calun
Georgia what's going on
Mary hey y'all thank you for taking my
call you're welcome how can we
help okay so my husband and I are babies
at this but after watching y'all for
about a week now we are on fire
and you have come up helped us come up
with a solution for our health
situation so we want to spend the next
year or so saving up for our emergency
funds we would like to get $20,000 in
that okay and after that we want to pay
off our home as quickly as possible um
investing everything that we have to get
it done so that we can demo it and
rebuild wow
okay I know that sounds kind of crazy
why would you demo your invest
but um we live in a farmhouse that was
built around 1880 and unfortunately the
additions that they did to it are
garbage okay and we didn't discover this
until after moving in and none of the
bones of the house are solid enough for
us to renovate it room by room which was
the original plan um very chiping Joan
gains okay but any um so um I just need
to know it would it be hurting our
family
to not invest in retirement or any of
our children's college funds or any of
that why we try to get this paid off as
soon as possible because the damage to
the house is pretty severe I mean we've
got broken joist and there's rot and
it's not something that we should be
sticking with for much longer and we're
hoping that if we can really pull our
hearts into this that at the
conservative end we can have our house
paid off in about five years well Mary I
look I I love the way you're thinking
like hey we want to do this we want to
try to do this really responsibly um I
will say there's a reason that the baby
steps are listed as they're listed and I
do have a couple of questions and holes
to poke in your plan um number one your
plan doesn't align with our plan and so
I just want to call that out we would
say hey after you finish baby step three
after you get your 20,000 saved you do
need to start investing 15% it would be
one thing if you're like Hey we're
saving for another down payment and I'd
say yeah do that simultaneously no
problem um and since you do have kids I
do want you putting away some money as
well for their college um and you get to
decide what that percentage is as far as
the kids college um but I do want you to
start investing because 5 years is a
long time to delay that process after
you've already delayed it for paying off
debt and saving money right and so for
that reason I would not do that and the
other thing that we can talk about is
why you feel the need to pay the home
off before you cash flow any changes to
it because you don't necessarily have to
pay off the home before you cash flow
any changes you could do them both
intentionally if you wanted or one first
and then the
next it's the house just isn't worth
putting money
into there's just really but if you pay
it off you will have put the money it
takes to pay it
off and then you will have because the
equity and everything so yeah so it's
not like you're it's not like you're
bypassing that step if you pay it off
that is money that you've put into the
equity of that land and lot and then if
you choose to rebuild it and that house
and then you're basically demolishing
the house so the equity is but that's
not tied up in the land in the lot the
the equity in the house which how much
like how much would the house be worth
if you were to sell
it um our estimated home value is about
2825 okay so yeah so we owe 147 okay
um and you think a complete Renault is
what you guys want to do or would you
ever look at moving or what are there
any other options that you guys have
looked
at we we love where we're at we love our
church we live in a very small town in a
very small community okay um and you
know we we do home school so it's not
like School Ties us down here or
anything like that um
but looking at the house it
just it breaks my heart but it just it
doesn't look like it's worth putting
money into trying to fix it at
all I mean we've put bandaids on it to
make it livable and safe for our
children and um we just had an infant
have you have you run any numbers Mary
on how much it would cost to build build
what you guys
want so um we found um house plans for
free and it's about
$150,000 to build that house it's very
small and it's we can build on in the
future okay
okay um yeah well I would not sacrifice
retirement for this I understand that
this is a really exciting dream and you
guys want to do this but I'm with Jade I
it would be simultaneous for me um and I
yeah and there's a part of me too I'm
like I I would hate for you guys to
still have $147,000
mortgage um and then have to take out a
construction loan you know on top of
that so yeah so I mean it's just going
to take a little bit Mary I think you
guys need a little bit of patience how
much you guys make a
year um my husband's net is 60,000 a
year
okay and that's including overtime and
things like that okay so yeah I mean I
mean I would say this Mary if if if the
house is as in terrible condition as
what you're describing like is it safe
for you guys to live in it for five
years yes we can make it work for five
years okay so it's safe okay I would not
I would not I would not sacrifice
retirement Mary I think that these five
years um are crucial for just compound
interests and starting for the future so
if I were you guys I would not sacrifice
that how old are your
kids I have 8-year-old twins a
four-year-old and a six week old yeah if
you wanted to to wait on kids college I
mean you you could if you wanted I mean
I would maybe put a little bit away for
them um but I just think that this this
this will be a slower process um than
probably what you're giving it credit
for so and who knows to Mary in 5 years
when the house is paid off and the kids
are 5 years older and all the things
like life changes you know you guys may
make the decision of gosh we may want to
move just houses in general maybe we
want to do something different I don't
know like so just know between now and
five years there's a lot of life that
happens so yes I would aggressively pay
off the house but I would not sacrifice
investing while doing that yeah I'd also
curious I'd also be curious if you've
had anybody like a like a contractor or
home builder come out and look and say
do we need to start from scratch or what
can like what can we do here because
that just feels really like we're going
to bulldoze our house and completely
start over cuz that you bought it for
almost $300,000 so it's worth something
it you know it's not like you're like
this house is worth 2750 you know what I
mean it's not what I'm picturing 157 but
yeah okay I where did I get 200 value is
about that's the home estimated home
value okay okay okay but my point is
yeah sell it in its condition but
interesting okay well I mean I still
would it just feels really drastic so I
would get definitely a second opinion
and I I think I like what Rachel said
which is in five years you don't know
where you're going to be and you may be
like look I don't want to go through all
that that's a lot yeah and maybe you and
and yeah and then again maybe you guys
look up in five years and you say well
we have some money we have some money in
our 401K that we've been investing and
the house is paid off and what do we
want to do now you know and that's the
beautiful thing about being debt free is
it does give you options and choices and
if you guys want to go build something I
would just hate to um lose complete but
if you want to yeah lose complete value
of the house but if you want to stay on
the same land and all of it maybe it's
what you guys choose to do but I I would
just say Mary to have a little bit more
patience yeah and definitely um not
sacrifice retirements in this and and if
the house does become unlivable for any
reason then yeah I mean be prepared to
go rent somewhere for a little bit and
all that cuz you probably have to do
that during the building process as well
in 5 years six years when you guys
decide to do that so I hope that helps
Mary thanks for calling too yeah that's
a very good call that's so interesting
um you know we've had a couple of calls
like that today Rachel where people have
gotten into a house and then they've
realized this is not what I this is not
all it was cracked up to be like we need
we need to get out of here whether it's
I just want to turn and run and move or
I'm ready to bulldoze the whole like
jackam thing and I just think it just
goes to show like planning and taking
your time and really understanding what
the steps are going to be long term is
going to save you a lot of time a lot of
money a lot of heartache and it's worth
doing that due diligence on the front
end so that you don't kind of find
yourself in this place where it's like
uh I got to make a move fast and then
you lose money because of it right this
is the ramsy
[Music]
show
you are listening to the ramsy show I'm
Jade warshaw your host I'm joined by
Rachel Cruz so give us a call the number
is8 825 5225 and we will do our best to
help you with the questions you have
concerning your life and your money
let's go straight to the phone line do
you have our scripture of the day oh I
do have our scripture of the day Rachel
tradition I know I know well I didn't
even think about it till you were going
into the fourth segment and I thought
into the show we don't want to break
tradition has we ever have we ever
skipped it oh we have oh wow once or
twice accidentally we wouldn't have been
the first look I'm glad you got my back
on that we can't look I'm I'm already
thinking about other things Christmas
miracle we it's only two paychecks to
Christmas sa we saved the show you did
all right scrip and quote of the day
hopefully it's a good one it says it's
Psalm 42 look this is you Rachel here we
are she Lifted Me Out of the slimy pit
out of the mud and the M he set my feet
on a rock
and gave me a firm place to stand thank
you Rachel for pulling me out so welcome
you are so welcome and then we've got
Rea McIntyre she says to succeed in life
you need three things a wishbone a
backbone and a funny bone come on Reba
wait didn't we didn't want to miss that
that's a good one I love back bone Funny
Bone and what Wishbone oh I love that
there you go that is so so good you're
welcome America you're save the show she
pulled us up out the slime y pit that's
what I'm talking about all right now we
can go to the phone lines uh where Devon
is waiting for us in Kansas City Kansas
City what's going on
Devin hey I just had a question about um
I want to see your opinion on dropping
my car insurance to liability only with
being in baby step two it would save me
about $700 a year but my car is worth
only about
$2500 so that's kind of the Dilemma
there yeah um I got to say I don't think
that I would do that liability I mean
that's like the bare minimum and we
would say that you would need at least
500,000 worth of liability coverage um
so I probably wouldn't drop it down
because here's the thing you want to
make sure you're covered no matter what
like if you get in a five car pile up
you want to make sure you are covered
right and so it's just one of those
things that you never know what's around
the corner and I find this a lot you're
not the only person Devon I think when
we're in baby step two we're so intent
on paying off debt that we're willing to
sacrifice everything to do it and a lot
of people erroneously think that
insurance because it you know it is
something that we add to our budget
right A lot of people think that we do
that after bab step to and that's just
not the case we always say that
insurance is not a baby step it's
something that you do the moment you
find out about it right the moment that
you get the knowledge and go oh my gosh
I need life insurance or oh my gosh I
need the right you know coverage on my
vehicle and there's a reason that we
suggest these amounts because it really
does protect you um in case the worst
happens and you run into somebody and
the damage is far beyond what you ever
thought it would be and so those are the
sorts of things that can really um
bankrupt people and put them in a really
tough situation so I would not do that
but I would use our coverage checkup and
make sure that you have the right
Insurance the right amount insurance and
that you're getting it for the best
possible price I would do that
yeah we I keep liability at the highest
that I can get it I just should know if
having the collision and the
comprehensive with it not being worth
that much say I it was my fault in an
accident getting another $ thousand car
probably wouldn't be an issue because
the car is not worth that much so I
didn't know if if it would be good
saving that amount because I'd be paying
about $700 a year um every year just for
a car that's worth about $22,500 and you
can't drop it lower since the value of
your car is
lower no the the collision and the comp
U how do we say the comp um they are
what they are um but the liability I've
got that maxed out as high as it can go
so okay well if you feel confident that
you could replace the value of your own
car
yeah and you've got 500,000 on the
liability you said yeah I've got the max
I can do I think uh 500 300 something
like that
um it's just the the portion of if it
Insurance replacing my car that part I
don't know is justifying you know
because almost about three years if I
didn't get in a wreck uh and it be
needing my car replaced I'd be paying
over the worth of my car pretty much I
could understand that
um let's see that's your choice I'm just
kind of thinking through that because
you're they're usually together right
you're comprehensive and your Collision
is together or are they
separate I think they're together as far
as I'm aware I would you know I can see
what you're saying and that makes some
sense I would still just check that
coverage check up just to see you might
be able to get it for less expensive and
that way you're covered on all three
fronts but I do understand what you're
saying about like if my vehicle is only
worth this much like I can cash flow
that if something happens and I get in a
wreck right yes yeah that's what that
we're in baby step 2 me and my wife and
and we've only got $88,000 left to go we
should have that paid off by April so
that's why it's kind of like we're about
to have more income coming in with um
another car being paid off and then
we'll be working on baby step three so
it's just kind of a weird timing and
that's what I'm trying to figure out
yeah listen in your case if you if you
have the cash to replace the car if
something happens you can remove the
Collision but if you move to an more
expensive car just don't forget to add
it back because you want to make sure
you're CED in that case does that help
you out yeah it does thank you guys
you're very welcome that's a really good
question thanks for the call it it ends
up being kind of that puzzle of figuring
out okay what do I have and always still
wanting to be insured right to a degree
that you get that like that's another
thing so it's it's all it's it's that
puzzle yeah I mean the liability is the
most important piece because you want to
make sure that you don't you don't know
what the nature of the accident is going
to hold and you want to make sure that
you're covered in that area so that was
a really really good call um let's take
another one let's go to Jason in soue
Falls South Dakota what's going on
Jason hey Rachel Jade pleasure speaking
with you um my quick question is uh my
wife and I are expecting some hospital
bills to arrive in the next week or two
and we were wondering is there anything
we can do now to take advantage of my
HSA or are we kind of too late for that
should we just keep stacking cash well
what are you expecting how much yeah how
much in medical bills
um not sure the total but assuming that
it's nothing more than what my health
insurance deductible is then it would be
$4,000 okay is that um is this on top
what what other baby step are you in I
just want to get a picture of where
you're at yeah we're we're in baby step
two right now okay and how much is in
your HSA right
now 400
$400 yes okay um yeah I mean you could
put money in that and use it I mean the
health savings account is a great option
for health expenses I mean that's what
it's there for that's right um so yeah
that's a great place to to save some
money versus you know you could just do
a high yield if you wanted um but yeah I
mean I'm trying to think the the the
rate for for
hsas I don't think the the rate is
really the thing because what I would do
I think what I would do and double check
this but unless you're investing that
HSA money that you're not getting a
return on it it's sitting there tax but
but it's protected it's protected but
what you could do is save up the how how
much time until this $4,000 thing takes
place um maybe two weeks oh two weeks
yeah just throw it in the HSA then like
once we receive the bills oh gotcha okay
yeah yeah I would just filter it through
there and then you're going to you're at
least going to get the tax shelter on
that money that you use for those
qualified medical purchases what I was
going to say is if this was going to be
like longterm six months or whatever
yeah six or eight months you could like
save it up in a high yield get a little
return on it and then throw it over
there but you know this is in two weeks
so so yeah yeah just put any extra yeah
any any extra cash you have yeah in that
HSA that's great I love it does that
help you out sounds good awesome thank
you so much J whoops I didn't mean to
cut you off I thought you were done
thank you for the call hope you got the
information that you needed I think we
covered it so good I love an HSA Rachel
I know well and what so interesting too
and I feel like even in the past few
years for us using it with an investment
and so you can actually use it as an
investment vehicle that's right and baby
Beyond baby step you know four five and
six that's right so it's a it's a great
place yep to put money whether you're in
baby step 2 to actually use for medical
that you need that you need expenses but
also in the future it's a great
investment tool too yeah that's right
cuz when you're 59 half that money you
don't have to use it for medical
expenses anymore you can use it just for
general tax yeah anything that you want
so that does it for this hour of the
ramsy show thanks for joining us
remember when it comes to your life and
your money you can tell me that you
won't do it but don't tell me that you
can't thanks for
[Music]
[Applause]
listening
[Music]
a